Khloe Kardashian is responding to the  derogatory comment Donald Trump  allegedly made about her that surfaced  last week a Celebrity Apprentice tours  told The Huffington Post Donald called  Chloe a fat piglet back in 2009 when the  reality star was a contestant on the  show good job Chloe  Lily responded Tuesday telling the LA  Times quote someone who is that  simplistic to judge things off of  surface is not someone I want running my  country and the denim designer isn't  letting this get to her she adds I'm a  tough cookie  so something he said that's not gonna  bother me  Chloe talked about her time on that show  earlier this year with Chelsea Handler I  just didn't care to do Celebrity  Apprentice I don't know why I just like  it wasn't for me and then my mom made me  do it  of course so I did it and I hated every  minute of it  you